[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es einer
meiner lieblings speisen aus der
arabischen küche und zwar machen wir mal
buhl märz die laster das ist
orientalische milch pudding zwischen
zwei leckeren ließ platten und am ende
würde noch mit zuckersirup übergossen
der ist so lecker und ihr packt auf
jeden fall mehrere stücke davon
zuallererst stellen wir den zuckersirup
er damit ihr auch schon auf kühlen kann
dafür benötigen wir 500 gramm gras 300
gramm was tat und dem saft einer halben
zitrone
jetzt werden zucker und wasser in einem
topf verrührt und anschließend
aufgekauft das lassen wir jetzt circa
fünf minuten lang lächeln und dann gegen
ende kann auch schon der zitronensaft
ihn zu studieren werden unter liste zur
verzierung auch schon fertig wir sollten
ihn jetzt vollständig auskühlen lassen
für die obere und untere teil schicht
benötigen wir 400 gramm weiß
beizubringen 400 gramm hartweizen gingen
500 gramm butter die habe ich bereits
drei stunden vorher aus dem kühlschrank
geholt bei 100 gramm zucker den
betroffenen hilfe und orangenblüten
wasser sowie rosenwasser
hierfür werden jetzt ganz einfach alle
zutaten miteinander vermischt am besten
macht ihr das so dass sie erst in gries
die hefe und den zucker gut miteinander
verrührt
[Applaus]
danach kommt auch schon die zusammen und
wird mit den händen zu einem
geschmeidigen zeiten bietet
[Musik]
zwischendurch auch das orangenblüten
wasser und das rosenwasser nicht
vergessen damit es wenig unverwechselbar
orientalisch schmeckt
im video seht ihr dann für eine
konsistenz detail fahren wollte und dann
könnt ihr auch schon mit der füllung
weitermachen
für den milch pudding benötigen wir 800
gramm mit 400 gramm sahne wieder rosen
und orangenblüten wasser 110 gramm
speisestärke und 70 gramm zucker und die
zubereitung ist auch wieder super
einfach ihr müsst einfach alle zutaten
ein kochtopf geben
hier habe ich schon mal milch sahne
zucker und speisestärke und das fröhlich
ist erst beim klümpchen frei mit einem
schneebesen und auch hier haben wir
wieder rosenwasser und orangenblüten was
hältst du es macht den unterschied auch
wenn es mal ein paar tropfen sind
probiere es einfach mal aus schmeckt
super lecker nun sind alle zutaten im
topf ich habe alles klümpchen frei
verrührt und jetzt wird erste herd
eingeschaltet und dann wird der pudding
ein mal aufgekocht
[Musik]
durch die speisestärke weg der pudding
auch sofort an und wenn er dann einmal
auf gekocht wurde können wir ihn auch
schon vom herd nehmen
[Musik]
eine auflaufform habe ich jetzt mit
frischhaltefolie ausgekleidet da gebe
ich jetzt erst mal die hälfte des teiges
hinein und drückt ihn fest mit hilfe der
folie wird jetzt der teig hinaufgezogen
dass es später unser deckel und jetzt
gehen wir in die formen den zweiten teil
des teigs zum test an
[Musik]
darüber gehen wir jetzt unseren
milchprotein
nachdem dann der pudding glatt
versprechen wurde kommt auch schon der
weg will mit drauf und da ist es ein
bisschen tricky das zu machen also bei
mir geht's eigentlich zu 90 prozent ihr
seht was den videos aber das macht mich
versuchs einfach könnten die reste die
euch vielleicht leben gefallen sind wie
bei mir einfach noch mal mit drauf wenn
ihr das dann soweit habt dann kommt das
ganze auch schon in den backofen bei 200
grad ober und unterhitze für ca 25
minuten die ränder die mir nicht so gut
gefallen die schneide ich vielleicht
einfach weg das ist gar kein problem die
nazis dann einfach so und dann schneide
ich mir das ganze so wie ich die stücke
haben möchte also nehmt eure messer und
tritt dann ganz leicht einmal oben ein
ich wollte lieber große quadrate ihr
könnt auch kleiner machen
in meinem fall hat ein stück für zwei
personen gereicht abschließend geben
wird dann noch von unseren zuckersirup
drauf es kann sein dass die zuckersirup
anfangs noch oben drüber schwimmt das
wird aber mit der zeit eingezogen und
das ist ganz wichtig dass ihr das am
besten über nacht aus kühlen lässt viele
stunden würden auch schon ausreichend
aber noch besser ist es über nacht damit
ihr zuckersirup komplett eingezogen
werden kann und werden sind unsere
monate bitterster auch schon fertig und
es schmeckt einfach unglaublich lecker
total orientalisch auch etwas süßes soll
es ja auch sein
und wenn ihr das ganze nach machen
möchte dann freue ich mich sehr über ein
paar rezeptfotos auf instagram und
abonniert doch gerne den kanal damit ihr
auch nichts mehr verpassen
[Musik]